la grande borne à grigny vous connaissez
ça mérite vraiment d'être visité c'est
un grand ensemble de 3000 hlm dans
lequel vivent depuis un peu plus d'un an
quinze mille pers
o des gens qui ne sont sans doute pas
beaucoup plus heureux qu ailleurs
le dans d'autres camps ensemble mais à
la grande blonde il y a quelque chose de
différent
il faut reconnaître les efforts du
constructeur
l'office inter départemental des hlm de
la région parisienne
pour offrir aux habitants un cadre de
vie agréable
peut-être plus bon en tout cas plus
insolites que tous ces quartiers terne
et monotone réalisé depuis 20 ans dans
nos banlieues
et cet effort là pour des hlm n'a pas
coûté plus cher croyez
à la grande borne on dit que les enfants
sont rois c'est vrai surtout pour les
petits il semble qu'il s'agisse là d'un
choix délibéré de l'architecte monsieur
émile eid il va nous expliquer ce qu'il
a voulu faire
il y a aussi dans ce qu'il veut quelque
chose de nouveau et d'un solide on dit
toujours à propos de la grande zone
c'est une cité conçu pour l'enfant ce
n'est pas un peu restrictif camp mais
non encore quand on dit pour l'enfant
c'est bien quand c'est pour les enfants
non ce n'est pas un disneyland paris
c'est pour la forme pour que l'enfant
puisse être autre qui l'aurait été s'il
avait été à hier qu'il puisse devenir un
individu
c'est en ce sens que l'enfant même pas
si telle expression de freud dix ans le
l'enfant qu'elle perd de l'homme est
évident c'est l'homme que l'on manipule
c'est pas l'enfant c'est une une
décision ferait résolu de ne pas refaire
l'abcp faudrait trouver une non
architecture qui comme la non poésie de
rimbaud est la source d'une véritable
d'une architecture du futur c'est
peut-être la création d'une matière
architecturale qui serait celle de
l'innombrable wait see longuement jma
sarlat désagréger larchitecture ce n'est
pas
un goût de pittoresques et singularité
c'est que je crois que psychologiquement
c'est un grand élément important
l'innombrable est une notion toute
récente de même que c'est injuste disent
elles le bonheur est une idée neuve et
il est fait que le bonheur est une idée
encore neuf qu'on peut peut être
développée avec une certaine
architecture
il offre un jour je voyais jeu mais
presque
enfin vraiment les larmes aux yeux un
gamin sabres aux petites semaines ans
qui était tout seul dans la place des
machins et qui aligne entre les pavés un
peu creux des indiens c'est ça c'est
pour lui que la vie n'est fait c'est pas
pour la marmaille qui révolte sur les
achats c'est pour la possibilité d'
enfant solitaire vous revient souvent
cette forme de ribennes les enfants
crise et heureux
bien que les appartements soit aussi
habitable aussi bien équipé aussi toutes
les prestations requises soit on ne se
contente pas de fournir simplement des
conditions de confort mais
éventuellement des conditions de vie qui
sont des dimensions tout autre qui sont
des dimensions mon dieu si bien d'ordre
politique c'est à dire ou l'intuition là
où l'irrationnel entre encore pourquoi m
temps habiter certaine place de petites
villes de n'importe où parce que c'est
pas qu'elle soit belle sait qu'elles
sont aptes à être habité l enveloppe
elle elle sécurise elle différence
l'horaire de l'urbanisme actuel c'est de
rendre tous semblables les gens dans ces
bâtiments hui est unanime et qui suppose
une vie unanime inexistante parce que
personne n'aime l'autre ont créé de
fausses collectivités il faudrait qu
aucun gré des singularités les
possibilités d'isolation possibilité
d'individualisation et la seule dignité
que l'on puisse offrir à des gens
démunis paille aussi d'être des
individus on ne peut plus si on
considère que l'existence est un ahmad
de confort ce monde sanitaire en tout
les gens semblables et désespèrent
sans qu'il s'en aperçoive ils sont et
comment ils sentent pas qu'ils ont perdu
la vie il se sent perdent quand on
regarde un peu la grande borne on voit
qu'il y a deux bâtiments qui sont qu'ils
sont ensemble de spaghettis grand frère
abel sa julliard mans les nouilles ou
lennon et ouais
est-ce que vous expliquer ce qu'est ce
que ça représente et bien la nouille là
mais ailleurs elle a une autre forme
c'est le labyrinthe c'est la notion même
de labyrinthe je crois que la
sécurisation de l'existence ne peut
s'acquérir que dans une formule
labyrinthique qui est d'ailleurs la
formule de vienne vous cantonnez dit
dans mon quartier du du 6e
arrondissement c'est exactement la ville
sont pas mais en pour toutes ces ruelles
dont on ne sait jamais brumeux j'y
habite depuis 15 ans je ne sais pas
encore distinguer la rue christine de la
rue palatine de la rue dauphine filles à
des rues des rues confus s'entremêler et
dans quoi je sais que l'on peut vivre
mais que je ne discerne pas donc ce
labyrinthe que je crée ce n'est pas
simplement le plaisir de forme de faire
des formes courbes et extravagant c'est
de créer des possibilités des guerres
d'égarement
quand vous revenir dans la endzone ce
que vous avez l'impression que ce que
vous avez voulu faire correspondre un
petit peu à la réalité ou bien qu'il ya
un hiatus ça commence pas socialement la
réalité parce qu'en fait ce que je lui
envoie quand on s'y promène sans surtout
les enfants
or il joue exactement comme j'avais
imaginé qu'il ferait il
ou à l'endroit comme j'avais pensé que
ce serait
ils font telle chose à tel endroit entre
les pavés j'avais dit tiens on pourrait
faire et je vois qu'un enfant fait ce
que j'avais imaginé qu'ils fassent
beaucoup d'attention du souhaite et 2 et
de réalisme on fait il faut pas inventer
sur un plan comme un architecte il faut
tout faire par maquette désir tiennent
dans ce coin là le soir le soleil etc et
imaginer qu effectivement ce sera bien
le fait que vous avez une population
très homogène vrai mais n'est pas gênant
est ce que vous auriez pas préféré faire
des jugements de toutes catégories
non ça le charme ça nous sommes les faux
je ne croise pas que la façon de vivre
de classes sociales différentes soit
assez homogène pour permettre qu'un lieu
les groupes
c'est un peu artificiel je vois dans
beaucoup de plans massifs en tenaille
adéquat et on saupoudre de groupements
de maisons plus coûteuse un ensemble je
pense qu'un ensemble un quartier même
d'une vieille ville est une chose que l'
équilibre des choses a fini par en
bramant jeune et je crois que le bonheur
y est plus plus probable dans cette
unanimité que dans des divisions qui
créerait des hostilités
ou alors il faudrait revenir à l'ancien
c'est à dire que dans la maison de
guermantes habite est effectivement j'ai
bien effectivement vous avez tout de
même fait une ville basque est une ville
où la composition sociologique est tout
de même un peu plus c'est à dire c'est
une chez pas la composition qui a été
déterminante j'ai le fait qu'on m'a
demandé de faire dévier laine et des
habitations individuelles et il s'est
trouvé que ça s'est occupé d'une façon
privilégiée curieux te fait les loyers
sont plus du tout bâtir un futur on
s'accoutume 70 mines francs
l'appartement
ici ça coûte 20 à équivalence donc
effectivement ça crée une sorte de
différenciation
si on a fait cet effort extraordinaire
de la folie comme essence s'est pas
trompé qui quand c'est pour plaire à
certains de ces tirs n'a ni meilleur ni
ni plus mauvaise d'être en colère c'est
au contraire un effort honnête et
supplémentaires d'améliorer un lieu à
quoi on est contraint par de parler par
des grésillés non confrères c'est un
lieu de gaieté non pas du tout pour
cacher quoi que ce soit
tous
et dans l'ensemble il n'y a pas de
terrain vague parce que les espaces
verts sont s'ils sont bien entretenues
assez réglementée vous vous avez laissé
des terrains vagues vague n'est pas le
terme j'ai fait que tout m'a plu soit
praticable et non pas simplement des
décors bourgeois pour être vue de la
fnege sont pas des terrains vagues tout
est présente retenu très soigné très
coûteux ça coûtait très cher de faire
ces grandes pelouses de faire ses fruits
vers s'est pas déversée rocher tout a
été très couture beaucoup plus coûteux
que le rien à quoi on habitue les gens
par facilité
ce sont des terrains praticables des
terrains pour que justement les gens
puissent vivre dessus et non pas
simplement devant révisé de n'être pas
conventionnel s'était pas on sait pas
essayer de ne pas l'être
on essaye pas des choses pareilles on
est ce clown et il se trouve que c'est
que ce n'est pas semblable à d'autres
choses mais croyez bien que je n'ai pas
ici
disons que ça n'est pas conventionnel le
monde futur ressemblera l'architecturé
nous faisons donc c'est pour ça que je
ne sais si grave d'en faire il faut pas
le faire à la légère
c'est le moule de la vie c'est la
préfiguration d'un futur c'est le
conditionnement totale du monde c'est
loin pas rien c'est ce qui fait le
manque cité